use regret to fuel you  i imagine my life at 100 looking back on  this moment saying  would i regret quitting  it's very rarely the things that you do  that you regret it's the things that you  don't do  so what i regret not continuing  would i regret not giving it my all  and i try to adopt the mantra that  i would rather know and fail than not  know  i would rather know and fail than not  know  so i had to see this through even if the  answer was total failure even if it  never worked out i had to see it all the  way through just to know because  otherwise that regret would eat me up  and so number one use regret when you're  struggling when it's not working out  when you're not getting results imagine  yourself being 100 years old looking  back and saying if you quit now if you  stop if you don't keep going  will you regret it  it may mean just realities of survival  you have to go get a part-time job or  even a full-time job to support yourself  but don't quit on your business